BE TGHT
OU TOPIC BOIDED?ED
IT DEFINITELY DEPE ANDT MEDIA SE
YOPATR
THERE'S VE
BUTTONICKY BACKS PENNSYLVANIA,
LOL NP
THE DAY , KEITH   THEENN DG
SENT AL TOS AND HOOL
EMNO,
WADE IO S E
TEACHERS SH,  ATION ISNGS NG ET
HISTIA
THERE IS SOME DISTANCE FROE
HE ASKEDERCKRP
RESPONSE, IT WAS MEE TEACHERS,
NOCOMES
VERVERKO ON THE CULLEN, A L
S NONCE
SHE DID ANYTHING ILLEGAL WHIE H.
ANRSSS TNS SURE HAT READS IN RT
STORMING OF OUR  L. DECIDED TF O
DIRECTOR THAT TEACHERS COULD NOW
IGERITOR OING MER.ERT DENTS AN
CTOR, G
HERE.
I BELIEVE THE STATEMENE MERE AS
SENT OUT OSCREEN.
I R  YEARS YOU'VE
BEEN WRITINGEXL DEALILR PUBLISHT
O PLAY.
E A SPECIFIC LEGISON
IN TEXAS THADO
TEACHERS TO TEAC WCALL
BE, LET'S ST S .I THINK IT'S CL
PROBABILITY BETWEEN RED STAT  S
TO T TO AND MORE IMPORTAN
RET THINTE
TH
E IEPROBLEM.
CHI  WITTHE USASTHIS AROTESTAMRA
SAID, ISS  APT
ISN'T THERE ERED ON THE
A TEXTBOOK FOR NEXT YEAR.COW DO?
OT ONLY CAN WE DO THAT IS TO
IN02 DECIDEDO  HAVA REVIEW OF  T
ABSOLUTELY.
THM ISOWED
GOING TO BE TERPRETED.
LET ME ALSO XTBOOKHE AREVOPAGE,E
BU'S ALSO CHANGEE
THINK, PARTICULARLY AT THE
TESTUDENTS AT TEXAS A&M LL NEVEI
ISTORY, THAT IS SAY, THE FIRST M
ISTORY, WE DID N IME IN
POWER.
>> ILSE, TOPSTY.
OF WHERES TAUGHT
TIMES" WTE PUBLIN OINGK T ERFULH
2020 WHERE
PARTICULAR AO EST
CALIFORNIA,
AND SHE SAERENCES IN
STATE, TART AISSANCE AND THE WAD
STATES OU
DOZENS OF EXAM.
I CA 1E E BOOGIEMAN, THEUCTIVET
DEEMED WITH SLAVERY OREC
THEYTOVE>> ANDF IT WERE MY IN CE
T Y
TEHAHAVEEDDUCING WHAT
WROTE ABOUT THAT IE WEEKS.BRSEE
TI THANK YOUG FACEBOOK
JOKE, RIGHT?